welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm fair and cousin sitting in for David
Pakman today David we'll be back
tomorrow
um let's move over to Finance right now
the Republican tax cut package that
recently went through they've been
selling it to everybody in this country
as if we're all getting massive raises
if you look at the tweets of you know
Trump himself Trump jr. Sarah Huckabee
Sanders Kelly and Conway Paul Ryan Mitch
McConnell they are all out there
bragging about the fact that American
workers are getting these huge bonuses
and pay raises from the corporations
that got these tax cuts and those greedy
Democrats want to increase taxes on
corporations even though corporations of
treating you so well right now right
corporations are just the best well as
it turns out and actually as was
originally reported before this tax cut
package was even voted on by the House
and Senate corporations aren't actually
using that money to give you raises at
all according to a recent analysis of
businesses in the United States 13% of
businesses in this country said that
they will use that money to give their
employees raises or bonuses one-time
bonus is typically 13% keep in mind this
is a tax cut package valued at roughly
1.5 trillion dollars and maybe 13% of
that is actually gonna find its way if
we can even believe the corporations
that say they're going to give raises
only 13% is gonna find its way back to
the workers the people who make the
companies run the people who make their
products who answer the phones who keep
things going on a day to day basis 13%
so where's the other 87% go well
according to statistics it's going to
stock buybacks the majority of the money
over 100 billion dollars excuse me over
one trillion dollars
is going towards stock buybacks over the
next few years
reinvestment as they call it into the
company but what it does is that it
gives more money to the shareholders and
does absolutely nothing for the workers
themselves it's not going to create new
factories and make new jobs it's not
going to increase benefits for the
workers they might get a tiny raise they
might get a one-time bonus but that's it
the rest of the money goes back into
their pockets when Nancy Pelosi said
that this tax cut package was giving
American workers crumbs Republicans
absolutely attacked her for that and in
fact they wanted to come out with a
piece of legislation I believe was
called the crumbs Act that would prevent
corporate bonuses to workers from being
taxed as if that was some way to I guess
own the libs on it that would be great
if they actually did it if they actually
passed it and said you can't tax workers
bonuses that would be phenomenal because
in most areas of this country bonus pay
is taxed at about 35% so those thousand
dollar bonuses that some people got
before their companies laid off
thousands of workers they actually got
about 650 cash in hand the rest of it
went back to the government which is
fine we got to pay for roads and schools
and bridges I understand that I'm not
the kind of guy that hates taxes but
don't sit there and say that a bunch of
people just got $1,000 when they
actually didn't but the bottom line is
that it is crumbs 13% might get raises
might and according to recent study
fewer than 2% of American workers have
been or have received either bonuses or
a page increase pay increased 2% that is
coming from the businesses now what's
interesting is that a new poll came out
this morning as reported in the hill 25%
of American workers report seeing an
increase in their paychecks so far this
year and 37%
Republicans say that they've gotten pay
increases as a result of the Republican
tax cut plan so that seems a little odd
right 25 percent overall said they've
gotten pay increases but yet
corporations themselves have admitted so
far only 2% of total workers have gotten
raises as a result of the tax cut so
could it be that people are lying or
could it be that this new poll with the
25 percent asked the question wrong and
just said have you gotten a raise this
year because guess what hope sometimes
people do get raises sometimes their
cost of living increase kicks in and
yeah their pay goes up by about 2/3
percent a year maybe but that's not
attributable to the GOP tax cuts let's
be real these tax cuts again by the
company's own admissions are not going
to American workers they're going back
to the shareholders the wealthy CEOs pay
less and corporate taxes then they go
home and they pay less in personal taxes
the tax cuts for you and me those are
gonna expire in about a year or two
that's all we get the ones for the
wealthy those are permanent and that's
by design yeah we're getting the crumbs
from this and anyone who tells you
otherwise is obviously getting a lot
more than our crumbs